voilà des mères en première ligne face
au co vide pas toujours facile d'assumer
localement de décisions venues d'en haut
mais peut-on faire autrement et a élus
locaux les différents échelons ont ils
appris à travailler ensemble sur les
questions sanitaires doit-on à la
lumière de cette crise
réinterrogée la répartition des
compétences pour ce qui concerne la
santé
c'est avec toutes ces questions que nous
laisse ce troisième volet de la série
vie de mère film de pascale carcanade et
pour approfondir j'accueille à présent
sur ce plateau françoise gatel bonjour
ans josette sénatrice et non union
centriste d'ille et vilaine mais aussi
présidente de la délégation aux
collectivités territoriales et à la
décentralisation au sénat bonjour avoue
christophe bouillon ou jours cette mère
de barentin en seine maritime et
président de l'association des petites
villes de france est avec nous également
jean leonetti bonjour le maire d'antibes
mais aussi c'est important médecin alors
nous venons de revivre cette crise dans
le regard de ces mères dans des communes
de différentes tailles
je commence par vous françoise gatel au
fond qu'est ce qui vous frappe le plus
dans ce qu'on vient de voir en bien
comme en mal dans l'action de ces hommes
et de ces femmes
ce qui me frappe et très sincèrement
c'est que les maires et les élus font
marcher la france et je vais prendre un
exemple qui m'a fasciné au mois de juin
dernier le président de la république a
le dimanche soit nous dit il faut que
les enfants retournent à l'école dans gi
joe merveilleux formidable excellente
idée le présent la république y rentrer
à l'elysée et les maires dans les 35000
où les ventes et quelques 1000 communes
de france quand une école comment ça se
mette en réflexion pour que les enfants
puissent retourner à l'école et là on a
le symbole de ceux qui ces deux
républiques le présent la république qui
veut voilà il donne le dessin et les
maires peuvent et parfois les maires
exécute alors que je pense qu'il faut
les laisser inventer des possibles c'est
ce qu'ils font tous les jours et
christophe bouillon du même avis
finalement les mères c'est eux qui ont
délivré en quelque sorte cercle voilà le
gouvernement décide des choses et puis
c'est à eux ensuite de faire suivre la
tendance
documentaire il aurait pu s'appeler les
maires ces héros du quotidien parce
qu'on a là des témoignages très
différents mais qui se rejoignent sur un
seul sujet c'est que et à l'agilité et
la réactivité et l'inventivité et
parfois un peu de dénuement aussi ils
n'ont pas toujours les moyens mais il ya
même de la colère parfois il ya aussi de
l'incompréhension rapport à des
décisions qui sont parfois prises un peu
rapidement il ya aussi l'idée malgré
tout il faut que ça fonctionne faut que
ça marche
faut que ça se fasse parce que il ya en
quelque sorte l'idée centrale pour
beaucoup d'entre eux que leur commune
c'est un peu la petite république dans
la grande banlieue onetti toujours sur
ce conte sur ce qu'on vient de voir la
petite république dans la grande nous
disait christophe bouillon n'empêche que
voilà une commune c'est une commune
c'est pas les tailles a pas les mêmes
moyens et on l'a vu dans ce film oui
mais en même temps il n'y a pas les
mêmes moyens mais au fond le mandat
local c'est un nombre d'actions et le
mandat national c'est souvent un mandat
du verbe est ce que dit françois la
soute à l'heure c'est que le président
dit et puis ensuite celui qui va mettre
en oeuvre les décisions qui se font sur
le plan national et il doit y en avoir
encore parce que c'est un état qui doit
assumer sa fonction régalienne
ensuite la mise en oeuvre elle est
effectivement par les maires le coc vide
est à la co-vedette un exemple évident
voilà on a dit on a vu des changements
de fin de phase et de volte face au
niveau national sur les masques sur les
tests sur la vaccination et on a décliné
localement à partir des maires qui ont
absorbé les différents chocs absorber
les contradictions absorbé quelquefois
les incohérences et qui ont eux aussi
été obligé de donner de la clarté des
perspectives à des décisions qui ne
pouvait ne pas apparaître près clair ni
ni génératrice d'espérance et jean les
multi vous dites ils ont beaucoup
assimiler les contradictions en tout cas
moi ce qui me frappe en voyant le film
c'est la masse d'informations qu'il faut
à
à accumuler en temps de crise sanitaire
surtout que tout le monde n'a pas les
connaissances scientifiques regarder on
va regarder un extrait on voit la mer de
biarritz qui va à la pêche auprès apache
vos infos auprès du sous-préfet réunion
téléphonique dans sa voiture donc là les
maires se branchent et on va pouvoir
avoir cette réunion bonjour voila mais
je préfèrerais trois mois plus tôt que
mes services comme ça je suis en contact
direct et je peux poser les questions au
sous préfet puisqu'on est très sollicité
par les citoyens sur ces questions
sanitaires et ma sécurité
les gens pensent qu'ils n'ont qu'une
heure pour faire leurs courses gens
pensent qu'ils peuvent pas l'air super
marché six supermarchés et à plus d'un
kilomètre de chez eux pour le sport par
exemple pour le sport est ce qu'on peut
faire du sport à 2,3 je conduis pour
qu'on peut courir pour qu'on peut pas
nager on a les deux on a ceux qui
pensent que c'est trop stricte et puis
d'autres qui pensent que attention de
vous laisser faire des choses qui sont
pas acceptables alors le voit ils sont
pas mieux informé que le reste de la
population christophe bouillon il faut
qu'ils aillent chercher l'info ils vont
à la pêche aux informations
c'est quand même un fort parce qu on a
parlé beaucoup de proximité mais aussi
une grande disponibilité mais même si
vous êtes disponible vous avez beaucoup
de choses à faire et c'est vrai que vous
êtes assailli d'appels standard
téléphonique ou à l'accueil des mairies
au soir par exemple d'une conférence de
presse du premier ministre vous avez des
appels la faim le lendemain j'imagine
pour vous demander comment faire
à peine la séance de presse se terminer
que vous avez déjà des appels des
parents d'élèves du personnel municipal
des habitants qui vous disent bon
comment ça se passe concrètement demain
matin à 8 heures et c'est vrai que c'est
difficile parce que on donne le
sentiment finalement qu' on est sur le
pied de guerre et que en appuyant sur un
bouton vous avez tout d'un coup le
personnel municipal qui est actionné et
qui répondent aux consignes qui sont
données du sommet la vérité vous savez
comme moi c'est que ça demande du temps
de préparation aussi et puis souvent
c'est ce que je regrette sa montre aussi
parfois l'incompréhension de la part du
sommet de l'état sur la façon dont ça
fonctionne dans une municipalité qu'on a
fait des concerts parenthèse jean castex
avant d'être nommé ministre était maire
de prades oui mais regardez quand vous
faites des conférences de presse le soir
en fin de journée croyez sérieusement
que quand vous êtes dans une commune
surtout une petite ville est ce que vous
pouvez comme ça réunir votre personnel
est ce que vous pouvez avoir un
interlocuteur au bout du fil il fallait
certes eu tôt fait il faudrait faire
plus tôt faudrait donner l'information
je peux comprendre qu'il ya une forme de
d'exclusivité on essaye de faire en
sorte que on soit accroché à la
conférence de presse mais ayons
confiance au maire nous sommes là en
responsabilité donc on donne les
consignes avant pour qu'on les mette en
oeuvre dans les meilleurs délais ça
c'est très intéressant françoise gatel
d'enjeux de communication en politique
en l'occurrence dans un temps de crise
comme celui qu'on vit dans la cette
crise sanitaire
il est très important c'est ce qu'il
faut redire aussi si comme un contexte
absolument particulier de décalage des
élections municipales qui ont fait que
les gens sont rentrés en fonction de ta
et qu'on a beaucoup de nouveaux maires
qui n'ont pas eu le temps de prendre
connaissance du champ de la
responsabilité et de s'organiser comme
on le fait d'habitude et que les gens
sont si éloignées de leur équipe et que
les choses elle porte sur le même ce que
c'est le maire qui incarne la république
monsieur le maire ou madame le maire où
est ce que je vais pouvoir me faire
vacciner est ce que mon enfant va
pouvoir aller à l'école et ce ne sont
pas les experts et donc non mais les
mains non mais y sont ils sont
redoutables parce que sincèrement
regarder dans l'ensemble des communes de
france sur cette crise à gérer qui était
difficile compliqué où les maires il
avait les infos traita et c'est tout le
monde leur demander d comme est ce qu'il
y a eu des dysfonctionnements sur le
champ des responsabilités des mères non
il n'y a eu aucun risque sanitaire née
du fait de camer aurait mal appliquer
des consignes dont ça veut dire quand
même que si on tire les leçons de tout
ça c'est que ces crises elle est
révélatrice de la capacité de faire des
élus et que l'état ferait bien de se
dégager des protocoles sanitaires de 84
pages pour donner l'esprit donne un
cadre et laisser les maires ils n'ont
pas digéré le meur et 84 pages pourquoi
là quand vous avez la veille pour le
lendemain et que vous avez un parent qui
vous dit me la 83e pas je n'ai pas
respecté c'est le maire casse et
en même temps si je puis dire il faut
permettre aux maires de s'adapter mais
il faut les aider parce que vous ne
pouvez pas laisser porter au maire une
responsabilité en matière sanitaire
parce que quand vous êtes dans une
grande ville c'est une chose quand vous
êtes dans une petite ville c'est
compliqué et madame le maire a dit
quelque chose d'important tout à l'heure
vous voyez que ce sont les maires qui en
direct et c'est d'avoir les infos de la
préfecture puisque le préfet ou le sous
préfet il va répondre plus facilement au
maire qu'au service et que donc on a dû
avoir une montée en ligne et en
puissance des maires pour que les
préfets répondent tout de suite et
immédiatement il ya un point important
dans ce que vous dites c'est la question
de l'expertisé jean leonetti vous êtes
médecin dont vous avez peut-être pas
besoin d'un conseil scientifique auprès
de vous mais parfois ça a dû manquer les
contrairement à l'état il n'ya pas de
conseil scientifique dans les
municipalités
comment est ce qu'on fait pour assimiler
autant d'informations complexes quand on
a pas à dire et je dirais presque que
c'est peut-être plus facile de pas être
médecin parce que vu le nombre
d'incohérences qu'on a subi le maire
déjà il se trouve en difficulté parce
qu'on lui dit la veille pour le
lendemain qui doit vacciner 1500
personnes en plus parce qu'on a une
dotation de vaccins on lui dit de la
veille pour le lendemain que l'école va
ouvrir et qui doit mettre en oeuvre tout
ce qu'il doit faire pour faire
fonctionner les cantines et les
réceptions dé désinv
mais en plus le médecin dit mais
pourquoi ils font ça
je veux dire pourquoi on empêche les
gens de nager voilà pourquoi on les
empêche de se promener en forêt donc on
est obligé d'avoir des décisions qui
sont des décisions préfectorales et que
donc le même le maire respecte mais on
est obligé de les de les accepter alors
que on a le sentiment profond que
ça n'est pas utile et peut-être c'est
même néfaste on a l'impression quand
depuis que je vous entends tolère que
dans cette dans cette crise vous le dis
j'ai très bien l'état décide les maires
exécute
est ce que le lien entre l'état et les
maires depuis un an maintenant s'est
abîmé françoise gatel les maires et les
préfets au étiologie de dialoguer ça ne
s'est pas toujours bien passé alors je
dis pas que ça s'est bien passé mais on
a quand même aujourd'hui des dialogues
entre l'éducation nationale et les
maires je dis pas que c'est bien mais
avant ça n'existait peut-être même pas
avant la crise 'le c'est pas si le maire
d'une commune de 600 habitants avaient
accès sous préfet moi je ne suis pas sûr
on va demander peut-être à christophe
bouillon là j'ai su que j'en suis pas
sûr du tout et que en tout cas
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les préfets
c'est la même chose
ils peuvent décider ils peuvent vouloir
mais sinon pas l'armée des ombres parce
que c'est ça et l'armée des efficace que
sont les maires on n'arrive pas à gérer
les choses et à maintenir le pays en
marche
donc je trouve que ce que ça révèle et
j'espère qu'on n'oubliera pas après la
création leonetti me disais c'est à dire
qu'on a vu que pour que le pays dans un
état de crise sanitaire imprévisible
très difficile volatile ceux qui ont
tenu le pays c'est qu'ils ont tenu la
france alors naturellement il ya les
hospitaliers il ya plein de gens
mais les mains les maires ont été des
essentiels c'est eux qui ont permis que
les écoles fonctionnent c'est eux qui
parfois sont venus soutenir les
commerces
donc je reviens à ce lien entre entre
l'état et les petites communes il s'est
amélioré
parce que franchement il ya des tensions
on l'a bien vu christophe on a souvent
parlé du couple maire préfet c'est dans
toutes les histoires de couple il ya
parfois de la vaisselle cassée
c'était des moments oui il ya eu des
moments de tension d'incompréhension mes
collègues l'ont dit et ils ont
raison de le faire mais au-delà de ça je
crois qu'un couple ça fonctionne sur la
confiance
mais un couple ça fonctionne aussi sur
l' équilibre dans un couple si il y en a
seulement qu'ils exécutent et l'autre
qui décide ça peut pas fonctionner mais
qu'est ce que vous demandez ce que vous
demandez plus de plus d'autonomie qui se
prend il ya des exemples intéressants
dans le film le maire de louer qu'on
voit dans le film dit voilà je vais
ouvrir un centre de dépistage et puis
c'est taper sur les doigts par la rs
l'agencé régionale de santé
il faut plus ou moins d'autonomie sur
notamment dans une petite commune comme
sur la question de la santé
chacun comprend que ça relève de l'état
en tous cas une stratégie on comprend
que la stratégie vaccinale
c'est la responsabilité de l'état après
dans l'application dans la façon dont se
débrouillent pas ce que dit tout à
l'heure que les maires sont des
expériences sont des experts dans la
débrouille c'est à dire qu'ils font en
sorte que ça fonctionne qu'au bout du
bout ça se fasse eh bien je pense que il
faut fixer les objectifs tracés un cadre
et ensuite laissé les maires faire parce
qu'ils savent faire
d'ailleurs la vérité c'est que vous
savez quand on a eu le protocole
sanitaire par exemple pour les écoles
toutes les écoles de france n'ont pas la
même taille n'ont pas les mêmes surfaces
on voit bien dans le cadre notamment la
question des quantités un final chacun a
fait avec et je crois que c'est ça qui
est important c'est de pouvoir dire au
maire qu'on conçoit pas tatillon
vis-à-vis que de qu'on leur fasse
confiance qu on les infantilise pas il
ya un point jean leonetti parce que vous
êtes voit la mer dans un département
dont on a beaucoup parlé parce que il a
eu il a fait partie de ces départements
qui ont été re confiner le week-end les
alpes-maritimes la question de la
régionalisation de la crise du coc vide
elle est apparu relativement tardivement
depuis un an trop tardivement selon vous
le gouvernant a fait des allers-retours
pas par moments et il a décidé de
manière globale et après tout c'est sa
fonction
la santé comme le dit monsieur le maire
c'est un certain pouvoir d'état sans
pouvoir réagir
chacun va pas faire sa santé dans sa
commune ou même dans sa région
et puis parallèlement à
ah ça de temps en temps et quand il en a
eu besoin est plus pur de la
communication pour que pour l'action il
l'a fait il a inventé le couple voilà la
lente et le couple préféré même pour moi
jubile qui tourne sans exister dans ce
couple quand même se coupent le maire
préfet en appétit se parler maintenant
l'illusion qu'ils ya c'est que ce qu'on
va dire va être entendu et que le préfet
va pouvoir décider c'est ni vrai ni l'un
ni l'autre
le préfet il informe plus qu'ils ne
concernent ils ne décident pas la preuve
c'est que il ya eu pour une fois dans le
département des alpes maritimes une
vision assez consensuel de laisser
sortir les gens en plein air plus d'une
heure de faire en sorte que le
confinement se reproduise pas dans la
dans la durée en tout cas le confinement
partiel parce qu'il n'a pas d'intérêt et
et le couvre-feu n'a pas d'intérêt
sanitaire est bien le préfet à la fin il
nous a dit qu'il nous comprenait mais
qui sait pas lui qui prenait la
diffusion lundi si tu prends elle a été
prise au niveau national donc faire
croire que on décide en région parce
qu'on discute en région puis ensuite
voir tombée du jour au lendemain une
décision du gouvernement
c'est là où il ya quand même une
supercherie
on ne suis pas dangereux mais non c'est
pire que tout faire croire qu'on dessine
en région alors qu'en fait tout se passe
dans un bureau à l'elysée je m'entends
très bien monsieur le préfet de l'homme
de grande qualité mais mais on lui a dit
assez globalement c'est peu plus la
peine de faire des grandes concertations
avec l'ensemble des nerfs qui disent
tous la même chose et la fin la décision
est inverse de ce qu'ils ont proposé
et quand on le dit au préfet il dit oui
mais c'est pas moi moi je fais remonter
toute façon l'adisq alors la question
que je vous pose à toucher la
différenciation selon les régions elle a
aussi ses limites dans le bon le film
c'est intéressant il ya justement
toujours le verre de loué qui dit bon
moi je comprends en même temps que c'est
important qu'ils diraient qu'ils
viennent d'en haut parce que sinon ça se
fait un peu la tête du client si j'ose
dire
christophe bouillon faut faire attention
vous accepter ça au moins oui bien sûr
ça c'est le cadre le cadre général
ensuite dans l'application il faut faire
confiance justement au maire faire en
sorte qu'on atteigne les objectifs
juste une remarque ce qui est de même de
match c'est que là où se prennent les
décisions on parle beaucoup du conseil
de défense sanitaire ya pas d lui et pas
un seul élu y'a même pas des
représentants des associations d'élus y
allemand voit que jean castex était
maire de prades mais oui mais
concrètement il faudrait qu'à un moment
un autre et on parle aux élus et à leurs
représentants aux associations d'élus on
a la chance dans ce pays d'être
organisée donc d'avoir des représentants
de ces élus qui peuvent porter ces
messages et les faire descendre on ne
peut pas être du sommet vers le bas
pardon pour cette question françoise
gatel mais est-ce que parfois quand même
l'état par un peu bon dos dans une crise
ya pas un peu bondir de clientélisme de
la part de certains maires parce que
c'est facile de tout mettre sur le dos
de paris quand les choses fonctionnent
pas oui c'est pas cessé ni noire ni
blanche je pense que c'est vrai sauf que
faisons une évaluation de la situation
encore une fois moi j'attends que
quelqu'un trouve un maire sur les 35000
qu'a failli aujourd'hui dans la gestion
de ce qui lui incombait ensuite il ya
moi j'ai trois points on est quoi est ce
que vous dites 1 le préfet peut
dialoguer mais je rappelle quand même
que les abeilles sont pas du tout sous
l'autorité des préfets
donc on a un vrai sujet ça veut dire que
là il peut décider tout seul et c'est ce
qui s'est passé en début de crise et le
préfet il n'a aucune consigne à donner à
la grèce clef s dépendu du mini et comme
la rs envie de faire carrière voilà et
qu'on a vu dans un département du
morbihan que moi j'ai suivi tout
particulièrement un préfet qui a
organisé une sorte de task force autour
de lui avec la rs avec le recteur cela
évite deuxième chose quand on pas ses
intérêts sans la manière dont les élus
avant de dissolution le fameux protocole
de x pas sur les écoles moi j'ai un
maire dans une petite commune quelques
comptines comme beaucoup de communes
avec des locaux qui sont ce qu'ils sont
prêts pas la transformer soudainement
problème qui était le problème de
l'hygiène et des règles sanitaires pour
le lavage emma lui la trouver une
solution c'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
c'est un maire qui dans son conseil une
femme agricultrice et le dit mais moi
j'ai la solution on va acheter des
abreuvoirs on va dans un magasin
agricole on achète des abreuvoirs comme
on m'aide en échange un médecin à
l'extérieur de l'école et va y avoir la
distance pour que les enfants puissent
se laver les mains après on mettra ça
sur le terrain ça a marché mais du feu
de dieu c'est avec l'argent on est
vraiment dans le ministère de la
débrouille des règles sanitaires
les enfants sont et les enfants sur la
ville m et ensuite juste pour terminer
sur la différenciation alors moi je vous
invite à suivre ce que fait le sénat
actuellement le sénat a émis 50
propositions en faveur des libertés
locales donc c'est pas pour faire
l'anarchie de la république mais dans
une république une et indivisible que
les maires et les collectivités qui sont
des acteurs et leur place dans un cadre
défini par la loi et on vient de lancer
une consultation auprès de tous les élus
locaux
voulez-vous de la différenciation
voulez-vous de la décentralisation
on a à ce stade plus de 3200 réponse est
un des scores les plus importants des
consultations ou les gens disent nous on
veut qu'on nous permette de prendre des
initiatives qui sont des solutions alors
que par exemple n'en avait pas besoin le
film mis à la mer de biarritz qui dit
voilà je fais mon centre de vaccination
et puis elle mais le préfet devant le
fait accompli puis finalement ça se voit
là tout se passe très bien
oui mais le projet initial prend
l'initiative voilà mais parce que
parfois et on a vu des exemples un maire
il a une idée et à un fonctionnaire valu
à c'est une excellente idée mais ça
n'est pas possible ça n'est pas possible
et pas dans un e mail en résolution de
situations et le maire il a cette
obligation de résultat dans quel dans
les quelques minutes qui nous reste vrai
qu'on parle voilà de cette articulation
entre l'état les collectivités est ce
qu'il faut changer les compétences
sanitaire est ce qu'elles sont bien
réparties vous avez critiqué françoise
gatel les ars les agences régionales de
santé qui sont souvent sous le feu des
critiques j'aimerais vous entendre là tu
jean leonetti parce que voilà tout à
l'heure vous nous disiez faut pas faire
de fausse décentralisation les ars c'est
de la fausse décentralisation c'est un
échec
oui c'est un échec sont souvent c'est un
échec parce que pour l'organisation de
la santé hors période de crise les ars
ont été faites pour ça et elle
fonctionne plutôt bien
mais en période de crise sanitaire
n'avons pas ce que le pays n'est pas
habitué à g
des crises sanitaires parce qu'il n'est
pas habitué non plus à faire de la santé
publique une priorité on s'est retrouvé
avec une difficulté évidente
regardez comment la traçabilité des
personnes a été difficile regardez
commandes les directives ce sont
quelques fois comme on le disait tout à
l'heure tu es au à l'autorité du préfet
en réalité les maires ne veulent pas
avoir plus de compétences ils veulent
une clarification des compétences et sur
des schémas d cadre bien défini pouvoir
avoir une liberté d'action
quand on dit au maire écoutez il faut
trouver des moyens pour que les enfants
puissent aller à l'école et ne prennent
pas de risque de contamination
on donne quatre ou cinq grandes
thématiques et grandes règles ensuite
s'il vous plaît qui nous disent pas la
largeur du bureau
la longueur du de l'espace à la cantine
la façon dont les gens se croisent
surtout que toutes ces règles là n'ont
pas de définition sanitaires elles n'ont
pas de base c'est peut-être ça qui parle
si j'ai bien compris mais au fond la
santé
c'est une fonction régalienne attention
à une santé décentralisée qui ferait
qu'à la fin on se retrouverait avec un
traitement qui serait meilleur dentelle
département parce qu'il serait plus
riche et est moins bon dans l'autre qui
serait plus en difficulté mais sur des
applications
les ars ont été impuissantes cette crise
c'est l'impuissance de l'état
c'est pas les mères qui veulent plus de
pouvoir
il faut qu'on il faut qu'on termine m
parce que l'on approche de la fin j'ai
une question pour vous christophe
bouillon parce que parmi les pistes
d'amélioration on a vu parfois je disais
un peu de dénuement de la part des
maires sk pas aussi à mieux gérer nos et
à mieux former nos élus dans la gestion
de crises sanitaires comme celle ci oui
bien sûr on a vu à la mise en place de
plans communaux de sauvegarde excédents
mais déjà les maires aujourd'hui ils
sont déjà dans
le fait de tirer les enseignements et il
prépare déjà les nouvelles générations
et la prochaine crise et la prochaine
crise comme ça ils l'ont bien compris
après encore une fois faut pas tant
former les élus il faut aussi former les
fonctionnaires d'état moi je suggère que
dans le cadre des stages vous savez les
fameux stage dena et bien il ya un stage
dans les communes qui seraient
indispensables pour leur permettre aussi
de comprendre concrètement le
fonctionnement de notre commune
française gatel sans parler de malheur
on fera forcément mieux
si dans quelques années il ya il ya un
nouveau virus une nouvelle pandémie
dans cette organisation de l'état selon
vous et à quelles conditions on fera
mieux
moi je pense qu'il est impératif de
tirer les leçons de cette crise ce que
une crise elle révèle des atouts et des
failles et donc prenons le temps ensuite
de tirer les enseignements de ce que
l'on a fait sachant que les crises ne
sont jamais les mêmes et ne se répète
pas de la même façon mais retenons
l'idée qu'il faut de l'intelligence de
l'agilité de la réactivité et de la
capacité de la nécessité de l'état de
s'assurer que là où il ya moins de
moyens les choses sont faites aussi
l'obligation c'est l'action publique
jusqu'au dernier kilomètre
y compris quand les choses sont très
gras avec compliqué je retiens aussi ce
que vous nous disiez tout à l'heure il
va falloir garder la mémoire de tout ce
qu'on dit est en train de se dire là
voilà un pour que les prochains élus
sachent aussi tirer avec 2,6 et de ce
qui s'est passé le mot de la fin très
rapidement pour vous jean leonetti voilà
il va falloir se souvenir de tout ce
qu'on se dit là par exemple aujourd'hui
au cours de cette émission mais de
toutes les nombreux rapports qui ont été
faits notamment par le sénat depuis
quelques mois
cette réalité est un révélateur des
faiblesses et des forces est donc
aujourd'hui on a instauré un dialogue
il n'est pas rare et il faut continuer à
essayer de faire une fluidité de
l'action je dirais de l'action
républicaine qui partent effectivement
d'une décision qu'ils exécutive qui
partent des décisions législatives de
nos parlementaires mais qu'ils aillent
au bout de la démarche de la de la
confrontation avec le peuple
il en va de la démocratie de la vitalité
de la démocratie
si demain les hommes en accentuer la
fracture qui existe entre l'état et les
collectivités
alors à ce moment-là personne n'est
gagnant
et surtout pas le citoyen merci merci à
tous les trois nous avoir aidés à
approfondir je renvoie à un livre qui
est très intéressant parce qu'il est au
coeur de notre sujet d'aujourd'hui
qu'ovide 19 une crise organisationnel a
signé henri bergeron olivier borraz
patrick castel et françois dedieu aux
presses de sciences po qui est paru au
mois d'octobre dernier y aura sans doute
d'ailleurs des mises à jour à faire
puisque la crise n'était pas tout à fait
terminée elle ne l'est toujours pas
merci encore une fois nous avoir éclairé
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis à très
bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]